hello everyone and welcome back uh very
quickly to the second game of the match
Magnus Carlsen versus brag now and this
is the second match of the rapid time
section 25 minutes per player and the
Magnus has defeated pregnant with the
black pieces in the previous game which
means that now Prague has to beat Magnus
On Demand with the black pieces and that
is something that happens uh well I I I
don't know when it happens but it does
not happen quite often so it's a huge
huge you know a Herculean task that a
pregnant that has to overcome let's see
what happened in this one Magnus has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 Prague
of course if he wants to win he has to
go for the sharpest possible lines he
plays the Sicilian Defense and Magnus
goes for C3 the elephant variation and
even though okay it has been used quite
a lot even in this tournament um also
played against pregnant and but lost uh
Magnus obviously has something else
prepared we have Knight to F6 Ponte E5
Knight to D5 and now Knight to F3 we
have Knights to C6 so all the same as in
the game that we mentioned C captures on
D4 but now Magnus does not recapture
Magnus plays Bishop to C4 okay you have
to react to your knight being attacked
Knight to B6 Prague attacks the bishop
and Bishop to B3 and now Pawn to D6 and
okay Magnus trades with captures
captures and now we have Castles by
Magnus we have Bishop to F5 and now
Knight captures on D4 we have Knight
character C captures and pawn to E6 so
now Prague ready to develop he wants the
castle King side uh Knight to C3 and now
we have Bishop to E7 and Magnus goes for
the immediate Queen F3 he puts pressure
on the B7 pawn and there's no time to
defend that but also you don't really
need to it's not a very relevant Pawn in
this line so Prague just castles and now
uh okay well you could capture it if you
guys are interested let's say the queen
gets attacked the queen goes back now
you're gonna have to capture the pawn
here otherwise Bishop to F4 will win you
the exchange so you have to move the
queen still bash up to F4 and once The
Rook moves Rook 8 to D1 the other Rook
will come to E1 and the white will have
an excellent possession for example
Queen F6 Rook D1 and all of your uh
pieces are very nicely developed so
instead we have Pawn to D5 by Magnus uh
and we have uh after D5 Bishop to G6 now
you can't play E5 to keep everything in
the game as the bishop would hang so
Bishop goes to G6 and now D captures an
E6 Magnus now ruins a prox pawn
structure F captures an E6 and queen to
E2 now he just puts pressure on that E6
pawn and there's really no good way to
defend it for okay you could go maybe
Knight to the D5 but then comes Rook to
D1 and it's not the maybe the best
position for black and if you go Rook F6
then still rotate to D1 attacks the
Queen Once the queen moves you're gonna
kick away the rook and then capture on
E6 probably with the queen trade Queens
so it's very very hard to play this with
black especially if you have to win on
demand which Prague most certainly does
so he plays King to a trade he on pins
and now Magnus doesn't even try to
improve his position if he was playing
this uh as a real game trying to win he
would play probably Rook to D1 at first
again and Tempo on the queen and only
then capture and E6 but here he doesn't
need it he plays Queen captures on E6
Queen captures with Bishop captures and
E6 and now Bishop to C5 uh now Magnus
plays Bishop to E3 where you have to
trade if you don't trade of course
Prague wants as many pieces on the board
as possible but if you move then Magnus
just will improve his position and have
the the monster Bishop pair here so
Prague traded Bishop captures an E3 F
captures and now Rook fde-18 attacks the
bishop Magnus moves his Bishop back to
B3 and progri captures Rook captures on
E3 so now it's the exact same material
Bishops are of the same color two pawns
each on the king side two pawns each and
the Queen inside we have Rook 8 to E1
here proc played Rook captures on E1
Andy was also in this position that
Prague offered the draw to Magnus and
Magnus of course accepted as this means
that Magnus has now won defeated World
Cup as there is nothing more to be done
here for Prague once you capture back
it's the exact same material and you
know just even trying to play this to
you know create something here against
the player like Magnus Carlsen would be
well if Prague decided to call it a day
here then you know that you know there's
really no point in continuing so uh what
does this mean for Magnus for Magnus
that this means that he has now won
every big tournament that there exists
uh like I said aside from the official
World random Championship but that's not
technically chess so he wins it all but
also uh not everything is lost for
Prague even though he didn't win the
World Cup uh he didn't get second place
in defeated World Cup which is a lot
more than Magnus was able to do until
until you know he was 30 years of age uh
uh he got to the semi-finals twice but
he got kicked out and now once he
finally reached the finals he also won
but yeah I mean Prague 18 years old
reaches the semi-final reaches the
finals of defeated World Cup gets
eliminated by Magnus Carlsen not uh not
you know a a bad
um uh you know uh thing to add to your
resume and uh another thing Prague also
qualified for the candidates tournament
2024 uh alongside his Magnus declined he
will not be playing alongside Fabiano
Corona and Egypt Abbas of all three of
them qualified via defeated World Cup
and joining them will of course be
janipomishi who is the runner-up of the
previous World Chess Championship match
that happened between Yani pondichi and
the dean liren so we already have four
people we need four more and then we'll
see who who will be playing in the
candidates tournament but yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it and
not a lot for Prague but uh you know he
he went for the Sicilian Magnus of
course went for the alapin and it's just
a very very hard to play for the win
with the black pieces against the
elephant Magnus of course knew this and
he just drew very very easily so it was
uh you I mean it's it's almost
impossible to to try and uh get a
playable position not a winning position
or something that you know you would
trick Magnus but just to get a playable
position where Magnus cannot force a
draw uh pretty much immediately and even
here it was impossible for proc to do
anything about it so yeah Magnus wins
but I I'm pretty sure we can always
agree that Prague wins as well I was an
absolutely incredible run and well I've
it's hard to save Magnus will be playing
uh in in the next video World Cup uh
maybe then Prague will will be able to
take it all the way but you know every
match is
um every match is uh is a match in
itself and uh you've seen what uh what
Prague had to overcome in order to get
all the way to here even though his
match against arjunetic AC where frog
was on on the verge of disaster on the
brink of defeat he was able to retaliate
the bonds back and then he want
everything in the tie break so it's a
it's a grueling tournament lasts like
forever or less like a month and you
know it takes all the energy out of the
player so uh you know a better luck next
time but yeah this is an outstanding
result and frog I believe uh got all all
that he could aside from actually you
know defeating Magnus Carlsen in the
finals uh but yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed that uh and this short
coverage of the free day uh fide World
Cup 2023 if you have any game that I
haven't covered uh that you really
enjoyed now I will have time so you know
do you use hashtag suggestion or just
send me an email email and I will go
over it I would like to thank Franz pan
card Brendan Mathis Josh uh gosh rajashi
chaudhuri and Robert Bloom for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and I forgot
to mention this is actually prague's
actual rating but once his rating gets
updated it will actually be 27.27 so
quite quite a lot of rating points
accumulated uh thank you all uh see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day